on n'est pas prêt mais t'es pas prêt et
ouais c'est dur c'est dur les mecs
pour plusieurs semaines bien
elle a pas de micro un bazar ce matin le
long moment d'absence du chef des
républicains au Sénat interrogé sur une
éventuelle candidature à sa réélection
en 2026 Mitch McConnell c'est figé
pendant 30 secondes
l'état de santé de l'américain de 81 ans
victime d'une chute en mars dernier
inquiète d'autant qu'une scène similaire
ces produits au Capitole il y a un mois
Franck Dieu pensait ne jamais devoir
remettre sa veste fluo et ses chaussures
de sécurité mais il a repris le travail
aujourd'hui rattrapé par la réforme des
retraites qui entre en vigueur demain
pas très content mais il va falloir s'y
remettre quoi
la nouvelle réforme concerne les
personnes nées à partir du 1er septembre
1961 pour elle dès demain l'âge légal de
départ passe à 62 ans et trois mois il
sera ainsi relevé de trois mois
supplémentaires chaque année pour
atteindre 64 ans en 2030
[Musique]
mauvaise nouvelle pour lui car il
s'était déjà organisé et son employeur
lui avait fait prendre ses derniers
congés ce donjon de 24 mètres de haut
qui est servi de prison jusqu'en 1945 et
le plus vieux monument de la ville les
deviné ce qu'il en a fait des cachots
ouvrez-moi par pitié moi je partais en
Bretagne donc j'étais en Bretagne là la
dernière minute nous demandait de
reprendre quand on est vraiment en fin
de carrière comme ça c'est pas très
humain je trouve cette réforme
engagement phare du président Macron
signalement ce que l'exécutif présente
comme la fin des régimes spéciaux au nom
de l'équité entre salarié nous voulons
mettre un terme un certain nombre de
situations qui peuvent apparaître comme
des privilèges c'est aussi avoir le
courage que personne n'avait eu jusqu'à
là les régimes spéciaux sont devenus
archaïques à mesure que la réalité des
métiers a évolué et ainsi les régimes
spéciaux sont aussi devenus
progressivement plus injustes
[Musique]
elle a l'air bien cette viande il y a
combien de temps de cuisson là et 15
minutes de chaque côté
sont des Chinois qui sont harassés par
la culture 9 9 6 on travaille de 9h du
matin à 9h du soir 6 jours sur 7 fini on
claque sadem et on le fait savoir
joyeusement sur les réseaux sociaux on
se en reprenant pour se moquer les codes
des aînés à dit là-haut par exemple
c'est une chaîne de restaurant très
populaire en Chine qui sert des fondues
mais vous avez des serveurs qui peuvent
vous apporter si vous leur demandez la
fondue en chantant joyeuse d'émission il
y a soit réussir dans la vie ou réussir
sa vie vous peut-être pas réussi dans la
vie j'ai pas une montre
une Rolls mais je crois que j'ai réussi
ma vie réussir sa vie c'est faire
quelque chose avec plaisir bon j'ai 71
ans je la retraite j'en vois pas la
nécessité parce que je vais faire quoi
je vais faire quelque chose quelque
chose qui va pas me plaire
[Musique]
ça nous aura pas échappé la hausse des
prix et continue l'inflation à Bondy de
4,8% sur un an en août net rebond par
rapport à juillet l'accélération de la
hausse des prix est une première depuis
le mois d'avril elle s'explique en outre
par la hausse des prix de l'énergie avec
notamment l'augmentation de 10% du tarif
réglementé de l'électricité au premier
août ces derniers mois les exemples de
scheriflation se multiplient selon une
association pour ces carrés de fromage
frais deux petits grammes de moins par
portion mais un prix au kilo qui décolle
de 11%. ce paquet de riz micro-ondes lui
a perdu 30 grammes mais son prix a
flambé plus 35% au kilo
un phénomène dénoncé aussi par certains
distributeurs comme le patron du
groupement les Mousquetaires premier
engagement on va doubler le nombre de
produits qui sur lesquels il n'y aura
pas de hausse de prix ou il y aura une
baisse des prix ça fait 5000 produits au
total 5000 références
sur 5000 références qui seront contrôlés
par la direction générale la
consommation et de la répression des
fraudes bien sûr contactez fin du snap
n'a pas souhaité réagir ces pratiques
sont pour l'instant légal mais peut-être
plus pour longtemps le ministre de
l'Économie promet bientôt plus de
transparence en rayon quand je vois un
produit un Kiri par exemple qui faisait
15 g finalement il fait 14 g mais c'est
le même package et c'est le même prix
et on vend au même prix voir un prix
supérieur nous lutterons contre ces
pratiques trompeuses on se sait pratique
abusives je saisirai le Conseil national
de la consommation il y aura
l'obligation là aussi légale pour les
industriels de faire figurer le
changement de contenu lorsque le contenu
a baissé et que le prix reste le même
mais le mytho le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale a finalement
décidé hier de supprimer l'hommage rendu
à Martin Luther King c'était quoi cette
hommage c'était une vidéo donc publié
sur le site du ministère de l'Éducation
de la nationale on y voyait cinq
collégiens répétant les mots de fameux
discours de matin Luther King dont on
fait aujourd'hui enfin on a fêté c'est
un jour c'était le 28 août le 60e
anniversaire le problème aucun des
enfants de la vidéo n'était issus de la
diversité en l'occurrence ils étaient
tous blancs vous avez fait un petit
tweet parce que France Inter a parlé
d'un clip raté vous avez mis vous blanc
égal raté je crois qu'on va le voir
d'ailleurs ce voilà raté
= des enfants blancs parce que France
Inter a dit face à la polémique le
ministère de l'Éducation supprime son
hommage ratés
et pourquoi il est raté parce qu'il n'y
a que des blancs qui s'expriment
j'ai rien dit
ils sont pas actifs on a là je suis en
train de faire lever il va se lever il y
a maman
vous faites peur à Mathieu
juste les vacances se sont bien passées
et on va parler du furet on va voir si
le cours il court toujours dans ça peut
vous arriver